my vision for Africa hopefully to be
realizable for Africa perfume in Italian
has become difficult I want to have a
vision my vision is why i have very
dedicated from a honest and footballs
leaders to really be able to stand with
you and with their own people move the
dishes forward we are lagging behind the
Millennium Development Goals I can say
we're basically perfect at the cordon we
are the ones laughing I don't think we
are doing much about it we are talking
about about it but we need to listen I
don't even believe every generation for
the ester group of guys with nominee so
my vision is for organized way our
leaders should turn themselves in a more
focused honest that little orb attack
and nationalistic we have dogs we can
slow it'll be the beginning of